[Musica]
[Applauso]
bene questo rumore che avete sentito non
è da scartare di una caramella del
regista ma non è neanche un rumore del
microfono è un suono della montagna è
una forma di espressione vocale
l'abbiamo registrata durante la rottura
della roccia prima di un crollo della
montagna ci parla in questo modo molte
volte si pensa che le frane che sono un
po questo cambio di vestiti
c'è un evento assolutamente naturale che
avvengono nelle dolomiti ma anche in
tutte le zone montuose siano un caso
fortuito occasionale imprevedibile in
realtà sapendole ascoltare sapendole
guardare osservare riusciamo a capire
molte più cose di quelle che in realtà
non riusciamo con un semplice e rapido
sguardo le dolomiti
in particolare sono una storia a sé in
tutte le alpi quello che calpestiamo ora
durante le nostre passeggiate in questi
luoghi
centinaia di milioni di anni fa erano
atolli del pacifico come delle grandi
isole in mezzo degli oceani è difficile
immaginare ambienti così diversi
immaginiamo anche che quello che
percorriamo alcune rocce che calpestiamo
sono state le stesse rocce percorse dai
dinosauri
quando pensiamo questa grande storia le
storie di milioni di anni anche questo è
un concetto difficile da capire
il tempo geologico è una una durata che
facciamo fatica anche ad immaginare la
vita di un uomo è un battito di ciglia
nei confronti della storia della terra e
quindi capiamo un po anche quanto siamo
piccoli di fronte a questa storia nel
tempo e anche nello spazio le dolomiti
sono circa diciamo le rocce che hanno
formato le dolomiti nascono circa 200
milioni di anni fa
cominciano a
mansi ambienti in ambienti molto
profondi sono oceani sono mari sono
lagune materiale si deposita per
dell'acqua cementa e diventa roccia ma
circa 40 milioni di anni fa
c'è un bel lasso di tempo dopo inizia un
un evento veramente importantissimo
movimento delle placche le placche
terrestri si scontrano la placca
chiamiamola euroasiatica e la placca
africana si scontrano tra di loro e
formano una grande catena montuosa che
dalle dal mar catena himalayana arriva
fino alle alpi
immaginate l'imponenza di queste le
forze che hanno spinto queste grandi
porzioni di terreno una contro l'altra
si sono scontrate hanno in qualche modo
schiacciato quel quel vecchio oceano
hanno fatto emergere le rocce fino ad
alte quote immaginate che erano
materiali che siano depositati a 23 mila
metri di profondità le troviamo a 23
mila metri di quota
quindi si sono state sono state
sollevate di migliaia 5 6mila metri
rispetto a quello che si erano
inizialmente formate ma le tormente sono
ancora più particolari perché si trovano
in un ambiente tranquillo quieta una
culla come la vedete qui è una piega
dove sono alloggiate queste queste fa
bellissime famosissime montagne e non
sono famose per nulla hanno un carattere
unico al mondo
e proprio questa loro situazione
geologica in cui si trovano e le rendono
uniche anche dal punto di vista sismico
sono tranquille sono le uniche zone
montuose non sismiche se guardate nella
diapositiva nella parte bassa della
positiva vedrete un buco nella zona dove
sono scritti dolomiti quei puntini sono
tutti i terremoti che sono avvenuti
negli ultimi 500 anni le montagne
anche avuto una storia climatica diversa
un ciclo climatico sono state ricoperte
da ghiacciai
immaginiamo che le quote che
raggiungevano i ghiacciai all'epoca
circa 20.000 anni fa erano di mille
metri rispetto al livello del mare il
che vuol dire che tutto ciò che stava
sotto i mille metri di quota era
ricoperto da ghiaccio se vediamo anche
l'immagine che dietro di me
vedrete che i ghiacciai arrivavano
addirittura di coprire il lago di garda
e in qualche modo a sommergerlo fino ad
arrivare alla pianura erano dei ghiacci
importanti che portavano materiali fino
a fondovalle e che poi mi ha dato
origine anche le pianure che abbiamo che
vediamo adesso la pianura padana
se vogliamo avere un'immagine di quello
che era all'epoca il paesaggio vediamo
che in questo caso era una fotografia
ripresa dall'alto durante un periodo di
inversione termica le nubi ricoprivano
le parti basse delle valli ed emergono
soltanto le cime questo era il paesaggio
che si vedeva 20.000 anni fa quindi
avevamo un periodo caldo un clima quasi
tropicale poi un clima freddo quindi una
serie di cicli e la natura lo vedremo a
questa ciclicità in tutte le sue
espressioni
quello che noi studiamo in particolare
sono i fenomeni che modificano un po il
paesaggio no che hanno dato l'aspetto
attuale alle dolomiti questo aspetto
così frastagliato e dovuto agli agenti
atmosferici le piogge in particolare ma
anche alle frane le frane che sono
sempre viste come un pericolo come una
una cosa da evitare
cosa che è in effetti però sono un modo
della montagna per cambiare di vestito
cambiare d'abito si risvegliano in modo
diverso cambiano aspetto diventano ha
travolta anche più belle perché hanno
così un aspetto magari più fresco più
articolato e iniziamo a studiare nel
2004 quando la torre 3 for una delle
cinque torri che in realtà erano 12 ma
da ci da cortina se ne vedono 5 è questo
il motivo per cui vengono chiamate
cinque torri crollò un torrione di 60
metri di altezza
immaginate cosa vuol dire durante una
notte scompare una delle torri è stato
un dramma per cortina per tutti i
frequentatori perché era una delle torri
più frequentate dagli alpinisti ma anche
lì abbiamo capito che l'evento che
sembrava così improvviso in realtà aveva
dato già dei segni precursori
abbiamo cominciato a monitorarne altre
altre situazioni abbiamo cominciato ad
ascoltare la montagna a capire quando
sta cambiando il comportamento non tanto
la sua velocità ma quando cambia la
velocità c'è la sua accelerazione quando
accelera è un processo che diventa
irreversibile è un processo che poi
spesso dà origine a questi movimenti
importanti che poi possono portare anche
eventualmente dei danni abbiamo anche
scoperto che il clima è cambiato e ha
cambiato anche il comportamento delle
frane il riscaldamento globale ha
portato lo zero termico che si trovava
una certa quota cioè di un punto i punti
le quote in cui la temperatura media
annua è al di sotto dello zero sia a
basso sia alzato e che vuol dire che
molte zone si trovavano permanentemente
congelate non lo sono più
si sciolgono diventano materiali
disponibili al movimento e quindi
aumentano le loro diciamo capacità di
arrivare a fondovalle e così durante
temporali estivi cortina ma anche tanti
altre zone hanno dei problemi sulla
viabilità soprattutto perché i ghiaioni
che erano quelle bellissime orly che
sono i bellissimi orly che bordano le
cime dolomitiche vengono immobilizzati e
arrivano come delle fiumare fino a
fondovalle
anche in questo caso è possibile capire
quando avvengono perché hanno una loro
caratteristica e noi cerchiamo di
vederle e in un altro modo
abbiamo delle webcam non so se le
conoscete ma sono delle camere
fotocamere che gli consentono di vedere
se piove se ne dica se è brutto tempo
bel tempo ma anche prevedere un po le
vostre spostamenti
noi li usiamo per
illuminare per in qualche modo
fotografare una zona da diversi punti di
vista
replichiamo quello che fanno i nostri
occhi e restituiamo una forma
tridimensionale soltanto da una vista
ripresa contemporaneamente da punti di
vista diversi
questo ci consente andando a vedere come
varia nel tempo questa forma
tridimensionale cosa sta succedendo
quindi anche i micromovimenti che sono
il preludio di eventuali movimenti più
importanti per le cinque torri abbiamo
monitorato anche l'attore inglese che
grazie anche l'aiuto della guardia di
finanza del soccorso alpino ci ha
consentito di installare anche la
strumentazione in cima alla torre
inglese in condizioni anche direi
piuttosto difficili e vedete anche
facciamo l'esperienza delle persone che
lavora in montagna ci aiutato ad
installare della strumentazione molto
particolare che ci consente di capire
cosa sta succedendo in una delle zone
anche magari più non tanto a rischio ma
insomma in qualche modo più
potenzialmente movibile vedete le
situazioni sono sono estreme non è
quindi anche noi cerchiamo di lavorare
in condizioni di massima sicurezza
e a proposito di sicurezza e la cosa che
ritengo importante e anche capire oltre
alla voce della montagna anche il suo
respiro sembra delle visioni più
filosofiche della montagna ma in realtà
anche la montagna una sua forma di
respiro accumula calore durante il
giorno e lo rilascia durante la notte
noi abbiamo cercato di capire come
funziona questo passaggio di calore
immaginate il termosifone termosifone è
una struttura che consente di liberare
calore verso l'ambiente in modo facile
ed è fatto in modo ha fascino a strisce
elementi separati da loro tra il
territorio le rocce fratturate e
rispondono come i termosifoni cioè
scambino calore molto più velocemente
rispetto alla roccia in massa la roccia
sana non fratturata
e questa diversità di comportamento ci
cosa di capire quali sono le zone che
possono staccarsi potenzialmente
rispetto a zone più sicure
questo approccio consente anche a chi
usa la montagna per l'arrampicata o per
diciamo dei percorsi particolarmente
vicini alle pareti per lavorare e nuove
sia anche in sicurezza e droni è un
altro sistema ormai di uso comune cioè
si gioca anche alcol drone noi lo usiamo
per lavoro per avere un punto di vista
diverso rispetto a quello di terra e
anche avere la possibilità di qualche
modo fotografare delle situazioni che
non si vedrebbero altrimenti e ci
consentono anche di capire quando
possiamo intervenire per in qualche modo
anche prevenire le frane
ne parlavamo anche prima con il vice
sindaco di cortina che hanno
responsabilità importante in tutto il
territorio
quali sono gli approcci non soltanto di
controllare ma anche se possibile di
prevenire certe situazioni di rischio
le fibre ottiche
le fibre ottiche ci hanno consentito di
ascoltare la montagna la fibra ottica
viene usata per tantissime cose viene
usata per inviare segnali per internet
noi usiamo invece un problema della fise
fibra ottica
cioè quando le ho delle variazioni
temperature la fibra ottica da un
segnale digitale disturbato
noi usiamo proprio quel disturbo per
capire le vibrazioni che sono prodotte
dalle variazioni termiche e dal
movimento della roccia e la fibra ottica
registra questo in modo molto accurato
questo tipo di informazioni che
elaborate in modo facciamo intelligente
riescono a dare delle informazioni
importanti su quanto potrà venire un
certo evento
le variazioni del clima vi dicevo è un
altro elemento importante e tant è che
andando a vedere su 2 mila frane che
abbiamo catalogato in tutta la zona
dolomitica che le strane più frequenti
sono a quote più elevate dove si è
destabilizzato questo settore che era
permanentemente congelato e che adesso
non lo è più
perché si è scaldata l'ambiente
l'esposizione è quella verso sud est e
ovest cioè tutte le zone che in qualche
modo hanno a che fare con l'eclittica
cioè quel movimento del sole quindi
riscaldamento e raffreddamento e poi i
volumi cioè lembo luni coinvolte nelle
masse che cadono a terra sono sempre più
elevati anche loro al mese sono delle
elementi importanti che ci hanno
consentito di capire quando possono
avvenire più frequentemente certi tipi
di eventi
la variazione globale del clima sono
ormai a parte qualcuno che non ci crede
ancora
diciamo oltreoceano sono ancora sono
effettivamente un problema conosciuto è
noto il retro mento dei ghiacciai e lo
scioglimento di queste zone che di cui
dicevo precedentemente che si chiamano
si chiamavano permafrost zone
permanentemente congelate e la scomparsa
di ghiacciai di laghi alpini perché
spesso questi laghi alpini si trovano
tappati al fondo da del ghiaccio questo
ghiacci si scioglie e quindi si svuotano
come vediamo nella fotografia in basso
problemi di vario genere di instabilità
legati a queste questo riscaldamento ma
l'ultimo tema che in qualche modo volevo
trasmetterli e la memoria d'uomo ha una
memoria molto molto labile molto corta
soprattutto sugli eventi e che in
qualche modo intercettano i suoi
interessi è un caso di una zona non
lontana da cortina una colata detritica
sono queste ghiaioni che si mobilitano
con i temporali estivi da giugno a
ottobre è avvenuta nel 1954 si è
ripetuta nel 1957 coinvolgendo anche il
centro abitato nel 1968 nel 1991 al 1997
e poi negli anni 2000 altre volte la
memoria in qualche modo ci dovrebbe
aiutare a evitare di
in qualche modo utilizzare delle zone
che la natura in qualche modo vuole per
sé in questo senso così inviterei a
pensare di lasciare uno spazio anche
agli eventi che possono accadere senza
cercare di in ogni caso in ogni momento
di ostacolarli anche le frane su un
evento naturale
bisogna lasciare che la natura abbia il
suo corso
cercare di dare sicurezza alle persone
uno dei compiti anche della ricerca è
quella di applicare e quindi di dare
conoscenza per evitare o cercare di
evitare danni però lasciare che la
natura del soccorso l'uomo è vero è
protagonista però l'uomo è ospite di
questo pianeta ospiti delle dolomiti e
quindi nella sua piccolezza la forma di
rispetto migliore è quella di
accompagnare quello che l'evoluzione
naturale cercando di salvaguardare
quella che è la frequentazione e la
sicurezza
grazie
[Applauso]